asking then ladies and gentlemen you
will probably love
i awaddy on iwaddy a book by richard
iawaddy
exploring the work of richard ayamadi
is that correct
how how do you describe this book to
people well you know it it is a
it is a joke the fact um
the fact that
i labor that joke no it is very funny it
is very funny
it's um we've got our first quote
it's not meant to be a serious um
interview with myself the idea is
i thought it would be funny um that
i could be treated with the same
reverence of kind of great directors who
are interviewed at the end of their
careers like awesome wells or or
scorsese and you you get these huge
interview books asking them about the
craft
and i thought it would be funny the idea
of me being asked
not knowing anything and having no real
great achievements
trying to sort of talk about my legacy
now
seemed a funny idea to me but have some
people bought this thinking it's going
to be an autobiography kind of you know
richard iowa is a small boy and
i know that yet has bought it
it is out now it is out now it is
possible to buy it a lot of people have
said they might
been a lot of interest which for me is
as good as an actual purchase
yeah but it it so to explain it what's
the best
is it could you wow it out or something
i could read yes is that a good idea
well essentially it's um a bunch of
jokes
themed around film that could be a
description of it
i can read okay read it out and then yes
and we'll get a flavor
also okay so in it i i interview myself
um throughout the book um and it's
you know there's some dramatic scenes
there's a there's
you know there's a speedboat chase at
some stage
uh and and in this the interviewer
version of me
the you of me yes if as it were ask this
question
so i'll do a slightly lower voice for me
less nasal i'll back it off
do you feel your work is easy to label
that's good thank you
not at all that's why people try to
label it
they can't pin it down so they want to
put a label on it i think people who
label
should themselves be labeled they should
be labeled
as labelers with a little label
and then someone should put a pin in
them i don't like being labeled or
pinned
i won't allow it do you like being
labeled i don't think so
do you want to put a label on this ruddy
leans over
and gently kisses me on the cheek our
eyes meet
the kiss becomes full mouth-based
probing and deep
we end up making love
when i wake up arjuna is gone
i have wet myself
that didn't that didn't happen
sort of did well the book's a love story
with myself but is it weird being on a
chapter like this selling the book
because one of the things in the book is
how kind of silly interviews are
yes i'm i'm not a brilliant salesperson
of anything to do with me okay
which is um a sub-optimal position to
put
both of us in currently and i i must
apologize
i mean really primarily to you
you have had a weird experience where in
the i.t crowd
you thought you were playing a character
well i i did a lot of research um for
um that part um uh where i play a geek
um i i went online
and that was that was it
also graham who wrote it he said i'm you
know i've written apart it's for the
nerdiest person
in the world um i thought of you
so that was that really yeah there were
no voices
um i think well it would have been your
own voice
yeah i said do you want me to do a voice
um to be the nerdiest person he went no
no just yours
but moss moss is one of those characters
that does delight people
and even this halloween uh so people
were dressing up as
moss from the i.t crowd and uh you might
you must have seen this picture there
was a little girl do you know this well
look it's a cheap costume it's a czech
shirt
oh no don't don't don't dash your dreams
i will not this is a little girl in
america
and she's a big fan of her halloween she
went as moths
look at the what she's got the computer
the calculator watch and everything
yeah that's good right the emotional
range is too large though
you need to kind of dial it back i also
spoke to her
i said you've got to get there
because richard iowa has written a book
yes
[Applause]
before we talk about it i'm going to say
because it's true
it is a really funny book i say that
because it may not be
initially apparent when you start
talking about what it's about
yes thank you for preempting my poor
salesmanship
um because i tend to put people off
anything that's to do with me
so yeah well you're very kind to say
that it is very funny but
now you need to tell people what it's
about okay and
let me do some damage now so to say
it is about a gwyneth paltrow film
called view from the top i mean which
she plays the stewardess
this is the poster have you all seen
that film have you seen this film is it
just
i i saw it it's a real film i saw it
yeah yeah yes it's a real film i haven't
seen it
well buckle up do i need to see it
maybe to read it literally you do not
need to if you've seen
any film you have seen this film it is
very similar
to all films william paltrow plays a
blue collar worker
um i don't know what research she did
maybe
into whole foods one and she dreams of
becoming an air stewardess
she becomes one
that's the film but
here's a dilemma can she be an air
stewardess and
maintain a loving relationship with mark
ruffalo
oh yeah no no
the demands of being announced are too
onerous
she's got to hand out salty nuts
um little blowy thing she's got to
demonstrate
it's a nightmare so they break up for a
while
what should she do you're literally the
opposite of on the edge of your seat
she manages to reconcile with mark
ruffalo
oh happy ending despite the salty notes
[Applause]
are an attraction and then at the end
it is a huge gun battle
but this is essentially a sort of
academic reading
of it as if it's a classic i yes i saw
this film with
um my wife that's not a joke i
that someone would choose that i saw
this film with my wife and
i was so haunted by this film that it's
taken me three years to exercise
my system and i've gone through the book
in forensic detail
explaining why it's so important and
i've interwoven it with um things from
my life
it really is so important um to give
this film
the respect it deserves because people
haven't seen it
people aren't discussing it can you
believe this is the first book about
this film
that's the first one people aren't
taking it seriously great
it's a whole book and we need to have a
conversation about this film
but yeah but also as you say you do you
do weave in other things there's a
beautiful
evocation of your childhood christmases
in ipswich yes
and they celebrate christmas in ipswich
to this
they day do um my mother liked the house
very clean for christmas
um we we would have to clean everything
before
presents were given out which was on
christmas eve my mother was norwegian
but it really was a ruse just to really
amp up the housework
and um she baked a lot of biscuits
christmas biscuits which i've found out
aren't a thing no she just when you say
biscuits
you mean biscuits
[Applause]
out we put out biscuits for santa claus
okay okay yeah
well we got cookies i needed the
biscuits to have the energy to clean the
house
i just thought what does goodness know
about it does gwyneth know about this
she's not emailed me as yet
i don't know she may be you know in the
middle of a cleanse
[Applause]
very good
[Music]